[Music]
okay everybody I am so excited today
because I am joined by Christina tonteri
Young AKA Beatrice and Warrior none
season two is out now I am so excited
about this we're gonna be talking
spoilers so make sure you watch the
whole season first then come to this
interview Christina how you doing today
good
I also know what I'm talking about oh
thank God good that that would have been
tragic if you did it so yeah I'm happy
you watched it I just watched it myself
too I loved it and there's so many
fascinating things going on with the
character of Beatrice this season and I
like that it starts in Switzerland
now what I thought was interesting
though is this was like a lot of
important scenes with Ava and we see
that it's Beatrice's first time drunk so
I'm wondering even though she gets
frustrated with Ava how she is this free
spirit is it also you think what
Beatrice is most attracted to about her
oh absolutely
um I think Ava David Ava kind of
embodies every
want her own life
Ava has
an in Ava she sees kind of like she sees
herself so it's kind of like she's Ava's
forced to do something that she doesn't
necessarily want to do all the time she
has to do it for the good of the world
but she has the opportunity she has this
Freedom inside her that I think Beatrice
has kind of like stamped down on in her
life so Ava embodies everything that
Beatrice wishes that
she could be inside her oh I love that
answer yeah I I totally see that and I
also thought it was interesting about
Beatrice's character was we see in the
beginning of the season this jealousy
she has Brewing when Ava is talking with
Michael so were you surprised when you
first read the script that Beatrice
would be the one type to get jealous
yeah but also I think it's
think it's things that they don't quite
understand they're kind of hiding
everything's very high pressure and I
think in those situations the parts of
ourselves that we don't really
realized that would come out do come out
so I think it's understandable that she
does show that a little bit more than
you might think or that even I might
think in in you know her everyday life
but in those situations where we're
already under a lot of pressure we're
already trying to keep ourselves
together those things tend to kind of
come out and throughout the season we
see her acting in a little bit like
uncharacteristic ways so I think that's
all kind of goes down that same vein of
like being in a situation where we are
like very uncomfortable and very out of
our own uh comfort zone so that makes us
act in different ways yeah I like that
answer and totally through the season we
see our act maybe on character ways
which makes it really interesting and
also just uncomfortable situations
you're talking about but this big
Turning Point early on in the season
where the sisters learned that Mary is
dead how do you think this affected
Beatrice losing Mary how did that change
her as a person well it's just it's one
less person to be
you're in the situation and you you had
been holding out hope against hope that
she might be okay she might turn up and
this is one of your family and they're
they're gone and you didn't even get to
say goodbye so I think that definitely
puts her in a much more again
uncomfortable position where like I now
there's just it's one less
thing to be able to depend on one less
you know Pillar of Strength to be able
to count on yeah totally and uh it's
interesting to see how the whole group
kind of moves on from that and I also
think it's interesting too because ever
since we've met Beatrice even in season
one you know she's always on guard not
trusting of people where do you think
that when you just even first read the
character where do you did you feel that
really roots from in her why is that
such a big thing about her
well I think it's as she grew up in a
very religious family and and her
education was all based in in this kind
of
culture of
it's very narrow the parameters of who
you were allowed to be
um I'm not saying that every religion is
that that or that that is how it is for
everyone but for her I think it was very
narrow she was allowed to be on this or
this and anything in between but nothing
bigger than that little box
and I think she learned very early on
that if she exhibited any kind of
behavior that was outside of that box
you would get you know slapped on the
wrist or whatever right then in her
family
um and I think once you
've experience that kind of thing from
your own family you kind of
start to think well if my own family can
do it
blown everybody else as well I think it
does come from a place of fear
um I think it is one of her weaknesses
that she tries to very hard tries to to
mask with that kind of like detachedness
but
yeah I think this season we start to see
a little bit more of uh
her starting to let go of her emotions
not always in a very controlled manner
yeah I like that I like you mentioned
the mask too and I feel like that starts
to slowly come off and what I love too
about this season is how much great
action there is and big set pieces but
also like episode three this Museum
Heist which was nuts and then episode
four of this great church battle so my
question is do you do your own stunts
and was there any stunts that you were
most nervous about if you do do your own
stones
we all did a lot of our own stunts the
stunt team was so great at training us
and we really all put in the time they
definitely put in double the time to
make us all up up to par
um obviously there are some things that
you just for safety cannot do and you
would need more time to train but I
think we all I mean did very very well
with what we were given so many so many
many gratefulnesses to to the stunt team
for that but um I think
I think the church fight was the biggest
like hurdle because it's a big one shot
right so we shot it beginning to end
every time we did it and we only had a
certain number of tries because you only
have a certain number of breakable
objects that you can break so it's like
and I think I think somebody like broke
one of the breakable benches by accident
that's like one less that we have but I
think that was the biggest challenge and
also I think when we got it done it was
the most satisfying and when you watch
it I mean like I watched it last night
and I was like
oh yeah I think it's one of my favorite
ones definitely it's amazing and that's
really cool to hear too that there was
that a lot on the line during it I like
that and it's interesting my favorite
scene of the show as a whole now is in
the finale your character Beatrice where
she gets to take down all these men in
this hallway with this like giant sword
thing
um was this the most badass you ever
felt in your career to this day and is
it seems like that as an actress you
kill to just get or be a part of
yeah I mean well that specific fight is
actually my stunt double okay Joe who is
fantastic
um but I mean it's a it's a recall back
to episode four in season one right so
it's kind of just like reamped that that
scene that hallway fight but yeah I
think it's
why else why else do we do this job
except we get to be in extraordinary
situations pretending to be other people
and there's like
the
there's no it's of no cost to us we get
to do it for the pure joy of it
yeah no I love that and I love that
Beatrice Scott scenes like this because
it's such a popular character in the
show and in the fan base so that was
really satisfying and I also think
what's really satisfying is we know what
this fan base everyone was dying for Ava
and Beatrice to finally kiss it happens
here and I want to know with you where
did you know like were these two always
going to end up romantically involved
together in some way on the show for you
or is there a specific time maybe you
found that out was that always the plan
I think for me it was always the plan
from the very beginning when when I
discussed that relationship with Simon
and with the directors it was it was
always a plan that it was going to be a
little bit of a slow burner but they
were meant to be together or they were
meant to be in love if not together as
we see
um at the end of the show end of the
season
but I think yeah I think it was always
the Arc was always working towards that
it was it was I don't I never had a
doubt that they would they would end up
at least showing their feelings towards
each other each other would you happen
to know did Alba feel the same way too
or is that something you guys didn't
even talk about I can't speak exactly to
her but I I think I think she also felt
that way interesting I would yeah I
guess I like that and uh it's
interesting because you just kind of
mentioned it too how it's like this
almost very like tragic ending in a way
and you know she lets Ava go but the big
thing was that Beatrice does not take
the Halo so then in the post-credits
scene we see she also is not going to
teach the new recruits and it seems like
she's moving on so can you get me into
her mindset there why she's not taking
the Halo why she's not teaching because
I think a lot of people are gonna really
want to know why
yeah I think well a big thing is that we
still don't know exactly what would
happen to Ava if the Halo got taken out
of her
we don't know exactly whether she's
gonna just end up paralyzed whether
she's whether she's going to end up
exactly the way she was when the Halo
found her which was deceased so I think
there's that and also I think she
already knows that her life path is
going to lead her in a different
direction
from the Halo
um I I think she's accepted as she had
already in the beginning I think she had
accepted that she would maybe be the
next in line but she's not the one to
take it and I think through the two
seasons she comes to the conclusion that
she's she doesn't want it she doesn't
want the responsibility
but it's not in a selfish way of like I
want to live my life I don't want the
responsibility I think there's a lot of
different things playing into into the
her decision there of not taking the
Halo from Ava when it's offered I think
it's she's very scared at the moment I
think it's it's very much like uh well
this is your last kind of
chance and I don't want to take it from
you just to save this object I would
rather have you know five more seconds
with you alive sure
um and then I think
again it goes back to the same thing her
her kind of leaving the the
church at the end it
it's she's realized that her life lies
elsewhere
interesting like she might still be
involved but I don't think she'll be
involved as much in a religious capacity
um
from henceforth
yeah no and I know nothing of future
plans oh okay okay because that's what
it was kind of leading me too because
that's a great answer and I'm wondering
Joe but you as a viewer Christina
watching this episode did you view this
episode as something that could be seen
as a satisfying series finale or one
that leaves a door open to a season
three is it both like how are you kind
of viewing it from your eyes I think it
definitely leaves the door open for
season three I mean the sword starts
glowing again we need to find out where
Beatrice is going
we need to find out what's on the other
side
um I mean if if Michael was over there
for a few months and he aged 15 years
then it's it's a lot can happen I think
it'll be really interesting to explore
the other side a little bit more could
you kind of power structure that that um
Raya and and Adriel and all of these
other
characters have over there yeah and I'm
sure the fans are all really hoping for
a season three and even if we don't have
a season three I think it'd be really
cool if you would you be down if there
was on the table a Beatrice spin-off
because I feel like there is a lot more
to explore with that character and like
you're saying she's conflicted about
certain things I feel like there's room
for that as well do you see that at all
I would I mean I would honestly I would
love that but I don't I don't know if
it's possible but I would love that that
would be I think there's a lot to
excavate there definitely
yeah even I mean this is both for for
Ava for season three and and for
Beatrice personally this is kind of like
an open door she's just she's left she's
I'm assuming starting a life of her own
so that can lead in any direction yeah
and you're right and that's what's I
think really brilliant about this finale
is having those open doors and just
there's so much passion to this show and
a really this cult following Die Hard
fan base so have you felt like amazed at
the reaction is getting that it's
getting this praise and that there's
people who are really like attached to
it yeah I mean mean I didn't know what
to expect when season one came out I'd
never been on anything like this
um but I mean the amount of
love and and
enthusiasm has been absolutely amazing I
mean just just to know that like it's
more more specifically like when I get
responses from people who are like well
I relate to Beatrice and she's really
given me courage to to live my truth and
my everyday life I'm just like like to
be able to actually touch someone's life
through a screen is is pretty incredible
so I'm I'm incredibly surprised but also
incredibly incredibly grateful no that's
awesome and I love your humbleness about
it and it's really just awesome that it
means a lot to you too because it means
a lot to us so everyone watch Christina
just kill it in Warrior on season two
it's on Netflix now spread the word
re-watch it we're gonna get this season
three and if not we're getting this
freaking spin-off it's happening uh
thank you so much for joining me
Christine I hope to talk to you in the
future
thanks for having me